[music playing]
ANNOUNCER: As a new day
dawns on Oak Island--
MARTY: Now it's pumping.
ANNOUNCER: --Marty
Lagina and metal
detection expert Gary Drayton--
Yeah, that's better.
ANNOUNCER: --are continuing
their investigation
of an old stone well on lot
16, located near the Money Pit
area, a structure
they hope might
provide new clues to help them
solve the 223-year-old mystery.
Now we're draining.
Here you go, bud.
Ugh.
You know, sort of--
Thanks.
Well, I think I'm ready
to get back in there.
All right.
ANNOUNCER: Having
successfully drained the water
from the bottom of the
well, Marty and Gary
are eager to dig for
the metal targets
that Gary detected one day
ago in the hopes one or more
of them might be important
clues, or hopefully
pieces of treasure.
Oh, what a sweet
little place this is.
Would be nice to
find another stone
with an inscription on it.
MARTY: Wouldn't it?
GARY: Unusual shape.
MARTY: All right.
We'll put this one
off to the side.
GARY: I'm trying
to feel for things.
MARTY: You wanna try your
metal detector on it?
Yeah.
Thanks.
[electronic beeps]
GARY: I'll put it in well mode.
Yeah.
GARY: [laughs] All
right, let's see.
[electronic beeps]
It's iron.
Whatever it is, it's iron.
That's too bad.
But I'm getting multiple
signals now on this,
ferrous and non-ferrous.
So there could be
different metals in here.
ANNOUNCER: A non-ferrous
signal indicating
the presence of
a precious metal,
such as silver or even gold?
I'm gonna try and pinpoint.
It's easier.
All right.
Here we go.
Please don't be a nail.
No, it is a piece--
ooh.
It's a piece of decorated
lead, by the look of it.
Really?
GARY: Put it in your hands.
There's two pieces coming up.
Got them?
MARTY: Yep.
GARY: Oh, it's a--
What do you got?
GARY: I don't know yet,
but it looks shiny.
[laughs] Oh.
It's a-- oh, it's a--
I got a coin.
MARTY: Do ya?
Yeah.
It's a coin.
Don't tell me you're gonna
do your gold dance down
in the well.
It's a 1 dollar--
Canadian dollar.
Can't believe it.
MARTY: You bugger.
Oh, my god.
Bugger all.
I thought that
was a gold coin.
I'm thinking to myself, how
am I gonna dance in here?
You'd do it.
GARY: I would do it, yeah.
I'm gonna see if there's
any more of that.
But that was like this
piece of decorated lead.
You could see there was
some kind of design on it.
ANNOUNCER: A piece
of decorated lead?
Could it be related to the other
lead artifacts the team has
found on lot 21 on the
western end of Oak Island
and at Smith's
Cove, both of which
may be connected to
the Knights Templar?
MARTY: I'm gonna get that
cleaned up in a little bit.
GARY: Yeah.
I am getting soaked.
MARTY: Hey, Rick.
Morning, bud.
Gary just found this,
a piece of lead.
RICK: Interesting.
GARY: Oh!
Detecting anything, Gary?
GARY: Definitely.
There's more metal down here.
But I just can't work 'cause
of the water pouring on me,
and it's--
I wonder how we're
gonna stop that, though.
GARY: It's filling up fast.
All right, mate.
I'm coming out.
ANNOUNCER: Although the well
was previously pumped dry,
due to the fact that it is
fed by a natural spring,
it has already begun to
refill with groundwater.
Because of this,
Rick, Marty, and Gary
have decided to stop their
investigation for now in order
to devise a new strategy that
will allow them to conduct
a more thorough search.
I mean, this is a
unique opportunity,
a well next to the Money Pit?
And being the first person to
get whatever's down in that
well out?
That's pretty cool.
Pretty cool.
RICK: But, save it for
another day, right?
Yeah, for sure.
But I'm confident there's
gotta be something down there.
All right, Gary.
A job well done.